w
（俺にはどうしても倒さなきゃいけない男がいる）
（そう）
（この男だ）
（俺はコイツを倒すために）
（寝る間も惜しんで練習してきた必殺技がある）
（今こそ、それをお見舞いして）
（奴をぶっ飛ばす）
ﾁｯ
（効いてないだと・・・？）
（どういう事だアイツ）
（ボールを回している）
（まさか、そのまま）
（うっ）
（じょ、冗談だよー）
やんのかオラ　おらおら
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーと
おはようございまーす
久しぶりのこのコーナーです
JUNJUN:そうだ
JUNJUNさんとの1on1のコーナーです
はじめ：最初にやったのいつでしたっけ
JUNJUN:2014年か
はじめ：2年前すか
JUNJUN:2年前だよ
JUNJUNさんとバスケの試合に来て今回で3回目
完全に負けて来たので
JUNJUN:今回”も”っておかしいだろ
*笑*
はじめ：夢の中でトレーニングしてきたんで
JUNJUN:なるほど
やっぱ多分JUNJUNさん日頃バスケやってるんで
JUNJUN:でたよ
完全NBAなんで
JUNJUN:いやなやつ出た
実力派のプレイヤーとどう戦えるかっていう時に
僕はやっぱ夢の中でのトレーニング
はじめ：夢トレ大事っすよね多分
夢トレです
はじめ：今回勝つイメージしかないんで
今日もゴリゴリバスケットやってこうと思います
ではいこう！
（実況）はいというわけでやってまいりました、1対1
握手ですねお互い
スポーツマンシップに則って握手をしています
なんで3回もしたんでしょうね
はいというわけで始まりました、先攻はJUNJUN
いきなり何を狙ってくる
シュート！
あっ
これが現実です
さあ続いて　はじめしゃちょーの攻撃です
ドリブルをつみ..ポロロロロロおっとっとっと
これはひどいですねー
完全にブランクです
ここからどう攻める
ドリブルついてドリブルついて
切り込むと見せかけてシュート
おっとこれは外れる
さあJUNJUN選手の攻撃
狙う狙う
はじめしゃちょー無駄に動く
無駄に動かされる
JUNJUN選手狙っっったと見せかけて
ドライ...ブですかねこれは
だが
これは
止められる
さあ　はじめしゃちょーの攻撃
どう出るか
ドリブルして中に入りたいのか？
ドリブルドリブル
ポストプレー
フェイダウェイからのシュート入りました　2点
2点です、この喜び、嬉しそうですね
JUNJUN選手の攻撃です
さあドリブルをつく
シュート！
おっと入った
これは2点ですけど3点だと思ってましたので3点にしましょうね
ドリブルドリブルドリブルドリブルドリブル
シュート打った！
エアーボールでガッツポーズ
何を考えているのでしょうか
JUNJUN選手の攻撃です
さあどう出る
かなりリードしていますね
はじめしゃちょー攻撃
ボールを取りに行くが取れない
シュート！
これは外れる
はじめしゃちょーの攻撃です
さあこの点差をどうする　おっ！
ボールを回す
無駄に回す
打ったー！
入ったー
いやーまぐれで入って良かったーみたいな顔しないでください
JUNJUN選手の攻撃です
さあどう出る
シュート！
すげー角度で、こんなん止めれねーよ
はじめしゃちょーの攻撃です
また回す
もうやめておきましょう、これ以上のそれはもう意味がないです
カメラ目線からのシュート
ハズレ
わずかにずれたか
さあJUNJUN選手の攻撃
もうあとがない
どうする
シュート！
あっ
うわあーー
JUNJUN:超疲れるよね
はじめ：体力が